good morning Hank it's Monday January
8th Sara and I are about to drive out of
Asheville on our way to Birmingham
Alabama I know you're going to be here
soon but in the meantime I thought you
should enjoy how pretty it is we're
going down the dirt road on the way to
the other dirt road that leads away from
Mom's house and dad's house sorry dad
geez I would like to congratulate you on
successfully completing the Strawberry
Hill challenge except that you didn't
complete it drinking Sutter Home wine
when you've been challenged drink
Strawberry Hill is like slow dancing
with Teddy Ruxpin you've been challenged
to wrestle a grizzly bear
Sutter home may be terrible but at least
it's derived from grapes Strawberry Hill
isn't made out of grapes it's made out
of strawberries
just kidding it's made out of apple wine
malt red dye and the fires of hell Hank
as you know I had surgery on my mouth a
few weeks ago after they sewed my gum
back into my mouth my mouth tasted like
cement and blood and burnt meat and you
know how after any dental procedure they
make you drink that like green gross
minty alcohol II stuff and then spit
Strawberry Hill it tasted
that was the Yeti Strawberry Hill tastes
exactly like that spit do you think I'm
funny
am i trying too hard when the whole time
Teddy Ruxpin it's just you get that way
around the camera tell Hank today is a
very significant day and I'll tell you
why it's January 8th and the first draft
of my new novel is due on January 21st
now I'm not a mathematician but I know a
couple so I called Daniel Biss and he
told me the January 21st is only 13 days
away aside from the problem of actually
finishing the book which is admittedly a
pretty serious problem there's the
problem that it doesn't have title I
would feel a lot better if I actually
had a title for the novel so that I
could say you know in 10 days I have to
turn in the first draft of my new novel
the baby-sitters club 26 Claudia's said
goodbye I've been thinking of using
either Shakespeare or the Bible you got
a lot of great Shakespearean titles over
the years like Infinite Jest the dogs of
war
brave new world in cold blood they're
also a lot of great Bible titles like
East of Eden Song of Solomon or
Rich Dad Poor Dad of course in the
biblical version of Rich Dad Poor Dad
Rich Dad gets turned into a pillar of
salt and Poor Dad is exalted above all
others anyway Hank I'm hopeful you'll be
able to come up with the title for me
project idea the brotherhood 2.0 book
club I'll read a book you suggest if you
read a book I suggest my first
suggestion either what is the what by
Dave Eggers or we wish to inform you
that tomorrow we will be killed with our
families by Philip Gurevich